Pour ne louper aucune vidéo,
abonnez-vouset activez la petite cloche !
Salut les Épicurieux.
Aujourd'hui,
même si c'estla pleine saison
je ne vais pas vous parler de la dinde aux marrons
ou de labûche mais des cardons.
Vous connaissez ?
Ils sont plus faciles à trouver en conserve
que frais sur le marché.
Ce proche parent de l'artichaut est cultivé sur
le pourtourméditerranéen depuis au moins 2000 ans.
Il fait partie de ce qu'on appelle
« les légumes anciens », unpeu oubliés.
Quoique en Provence et dans la vallée du Rhône,
Les cardons sont toujours consommés
surtout en période de fêtes.
Autrefois, il faisait systématiquement partie
du souper du 24décembre.
Il préparait l'organisme à l'abondance de nourriture.
Il faut dire que pour cela,
lecardon possède plusieurs atouts.
D'abord,
il est riche en fibres qui aident à la digestion
et à réguler l'absorption de graisses et de sucres.
Ensuite,
il contient de la cynarine
un composé polyphénolique antioxydant.
Je sais,
c'est pas facile à digérer.
Je parle du termehein,
pas du légume !
C'est lui
qui donne un goût amer
mais qui a aussi des propriétés dépuratives
très utiles pour le foie
en période de fêtes.
Car pour bien faire les choses
comme on lesfaisait en Provence
le soir de Noël,
ce plat doit être accompagné de six autres :
légumeset poissons
et de treize desserts.
Bon,
froid c'est pas terrible
mais chaud avec
un peu demoelle osseuse
c'est délicieux !
Comme il n'y a pas de viande
on parle toujours de repasmaigre.
Allez à bientôt !
Bon réveillon
et Joyeux Noël !